in this kilometer you'll learn how to  quickly deploy a java web application to  Google App Engine standard with Maslin  first at the App Engine plugin to pomme  de XML  then create an app engine web dot XML  file and specify Java 8 as the App  Engine runtime  I think in standard of support survey  three point one so you can annotate your  servlet you can also use all of the Java  8 api's and features such as string and  lambdas finally deploy the application  using maven once the point you can  access the application with the  project's URL on appspot comm you can  also deploy this application directly  from Gradle IntelliJ or Eclipse using  respective plugins learn more on the  Google cloud platform for Java  developers website